قراره مؤلمه لسد عجز يقدر ب 55 مليار جنيه
في موازنه جرم هانط ربعي وزراء ماليه
بريطانيا هذا العام جمعت بين رفع الضرائب
وتخفيض الانفاق لاصلاح الماليه العامه
وتخفيف ركود طويل محتمل واستعاده مصداقيه
بريطانيا بين المستثمرين
2028 سنزيد ضريبه ارباح الشركات الطاقه من
25 الى 35% كذلك قررنا بدلا من يناير
المقبل
45% على الكهرباء منخفضه الكربون هذه
الاجراءات ستؤمن 14 مليار جنيه العام
المقبل
اخيرا ردخت الحكومه لرفع الضريبه على
ارباح شركات الطاقه غير المتوقعه مع
تحديدهانتلي اولويات موازنته بالاستقرار
والنمو والخدمات العامه
لكن هذه الخطه تقول المعارضه انها ستزيد
من اعداء الضرائب وسيدفع المواطنين ثمن
فشل الحكومه المحافظه حتى وان تعهدت
بحمايه الاكثر ضعفا بزياده معاشات التقاعد
في ظل ارتفاع تكلفه المعيشه
لتصحيحه اخطاء السياسه الماليه لحكومه
الجميع سيدفع المزيد من الضرائب مع خفض
الانفاق على الخدمات العامه لكن هذه
الموازنه التزمت ايضا بضخ الملياراته في
التعليم وقطاع الصحه والطاقه النوويه فكيف
يرى الناس تاثير هذه الموازنه على حياتهم
يجب ان نحضر باستقرار ولا يمكن الاستمرار
كما كنا انا محظوظه
الوضع
المزيد من الضرائب ولكن علينا ان نكون
واقعيين في العالم الذين يعيش فيه
بعد الكشف عن الموازنه المنتظره لم تشهد
تكاليف الاقتراض الحكوميه تغيرا يذكر ما
يشير الى ان وزير الماليه نجح في طمانه
المستثمرين حتى الان ولكن كل التقارير
تشير الى ان دافع الضرائب سيشهدون اسوا
عامين مقبلين مع التوقعات بتراجع مستويات
معيشتهم باكبر نسبه على الاطلاق مصطفى
زاروه العربيه لندن